talking about black women where black
women from different cultures
that's why it's like
when black girls say oh they're the
least desired because of you know
eurocentric
beauty standards which i'm not saying
there isn't an element of that i think
there is
but then like i said it's like well
black women from other cultures they
don't have a problem
because different mindset because like
you're saying that like the girl was
talking about the last one she was from
uganda
right culturally
amazing she kicked every single box i
was like oh my god i think i'm gonna
marry this girl i could actually see
myself marrying this girl um but you
know she jesus cop blocked and all that
but
like it's true like
black women from different cultures
are different from western black women
they are they are
well it's interesting because they
always say like
they'll leave you for like a becky or
whatever right but that is not my
experience because i have two
ex-boyfriends and they like they both
were black and like they left me for a
black girl
or like when we broke up the next girl
they dated was black so i was like
i don't know
how old were they can i ask do you mind
me listening no that's fine um
he's about to turn 24 so you're younger
and then
well
i'm trying to think i was a sophomore
but i was a year young for my grades i
was like 18.
i think like he was four years older so
when you're younger and then four years
older so now
but i think one of the things that is
not touched on one of the things that
people try to stray away from generally
because it's a little bit like
controversial yeah is that the
fetishization
that people have in certainly like
interracial relationships
i think to some degree there's a
fetishization and i'm not saying in all
the interracial relationships i'm not
saying that but i think to some degree
there's that oh my god i shouldn't even
be here but i love it
but it's great oh my god i shouldn't be
doing it that's still the case now
subconsciously i think do you think do
you think white girls
feel that way now because we're so
emotionally you see when i go integrated
you see when i grow up right i'm 40
right so i grew up in an era where
the black guy was the cool guy to white
girls
he was always the cool guy he was the
guy that
was a little bit more dangerous he was a
little bit more to something that she
shouldn't do but she's doing it and
she's kind of rebelling against what her
parents say and all this kind of stuff
right you know what i'm saying so yeah
it's actually there was an element of
i'm doing this to be a rebel
yes a forbidden yeah was would you say
that was the same for
so you know as we said like in the west
the majority of the black community are
in the working class
would you say that was the same for
white girls in working class
yeah like i got approached like i won't
lie if i when i was go to clubs right
with my friends right black guys and if
we were to go to clubs that were like
mostly white girls
the white girls would stop
they wouldn't even give a [ __ ] about the
white guys anymore yeah they would stop
they'll be like there's some black guys
here girls yeah do you know what i mean
it's like whoa it's like to see that
it's like oh that was interesting but
then
a club that's all white
it's probably not a working-class club
it's a working-class club it's you
you've got black people indian people
yeah like chinese i mean it was in the
west end in it you know i mean but
that's what i mean so like if they're
not i completely get that if they're
from if they're in a class where it is
very
majority white
but if they've grown up in a class where
it's very multicultural it's very mixed
like the black being like oh there's a
black guy it's like well yeah like
because it doesn't get normal
yeah it's normal so i'd say like what
i'm questioning is is the fetishization
probably comes from those who are more
middle upper class because they haven't
been exposed to it as much whereas if
you've grown up with it is it really
fetishized i don't know that's what i'm
asking and i think a lot of black guys
fetishize white girls too
yeah
yeah you know what
i think that's porn
is the subconscious mind of the nation
i keep telling people yes you know
what's the most looked up on
porn sites
interracial
you know the bbc it's a thing on porn
you go on board oh you want to see the
bbc it's a thing bro like it's just it's
the subconscious mind of the nation but
people don't want to talk about it it's
like when you go on porn it's like what
do you mean by some conscious mind
because what it is is a place in which
human beings walk around the streets
thinking these things about people right
yes they think these things but they
don't say these things but when they go
on the porn side they're allowed to like
indulge in that [ __ ] do you get what i'm
saying so it's like it's the
subconscious mind of the nation it's the
place where they feel comfortable to
express their fetishes right and express
what they really feel like because what
black guy can go out in the public and
say you know what i really want to bang
a white asian chick
he'll be cancelled yeah but you can't
say that [ __ ]
but
you can do it on the pawn side can i ask
you a question do you think you can
fetishize
your own race someone who's of the same
race to you um
um
and if maybe
like of course i feel like they can't
yeah maybe
like no one's safe
but i don't think about this i'm saying
like the human mind is i love that talk
like psychology like stuff i think
fetishizing is such a weird conversation
because it's more like i just don't care
who people date
if you want to date your own race or a
different race i just
i don't give a [ __ ] like i just don't
care who you like what i'm just saying
like when it comes to
what's on the minds of people i think a
lot of us like i said we're all lying to
one another we're lying to ourselves
like people are walking around lying
it's like if i was to go in your porn
searches now i'd figure out who to [ __ ]
you up
sometimes that's how you feel on a
thursday yeah
does body count matter if you never find
out
oh no no
if you never find out no you don't know
do you guys ask girls what their body
count is when you start dating
it's pointless because they're going to
lie anyway
yeah but they're going to lie anyway
but like i've i would rather not know i
want to know to some degree i want to
know if you've had a chance i'll tell
you the only reason why i'd want to know
i don't want to know if you i wasn't
trying to pursue you if i'm trying to
pursue you don't tell me
really yeah
would you not want to know if you're the
woman that you will i want to know well
i want to know if i'm
with you and i'm thinking to get married
to you is the man you have had sex with
going to be at my wedding
that's what i want to know yeah and if
if he is at my wedding then nah nah he
can't yeah you know what i'm saying but
like if he's if you wouldn't know if he
was like a prostitute before you or
something
listen does the man know me
and is he going to come to our wedding
is he going to be a part of our lives am
i going to meet him
i tell you what it matters to me
everyone has a cv
or a resume okay for pearl right
your cv
shows what your past behavior in your
job has been it shows what you can do
and it normally you're hired on your cv
because it shows what you're probably
going to do in the future
oh your cv if you've been a prostitute
you might be a prostitute in the future
yeah i don't know yeah but you kind of
ask different questions to find out
those things i think yeah okay so i
think you wouldn't ask directly like yo
what's your body count but i think when
you get to know someone without asking a
question you can gauge what it is
you can gauge and sometimes they because
they might ask you what about you would
you want to know what
a guy's body counter is
i'm nosy i always ask
i'm just like i love she was gonna lie
to you i am i'm very nosy
so
but the thing is you you'd prefer
[Music]
a guy with
a high body count or a low one
uh lower i'd rather there be less exes
but i'm like practical in the way i
think it doesn't mean i'm attracted to
it there's a difference between like
dating like like wanting something
because it's like practical and like
being attract like obviously women are
attracted to like men that other or
men that other women want right but like
at the same like the way i think is
i i just rather there be less exes in
general and crazy girls ex-girlfriends
or do you mean
like either crazy can be either or
especially if he's like a good looking
guy i'm like
i don't i don't want all these exes like
oh my gosh and i need to know if you
slept with any of like the girls around
oh
well if you slept with your friends oh
it's over
i can't really no
if he's a really desirable guy
and he only casually had sex with like
one or two of her friends if she gets
commitment that's like an ego boost for
her
but it's like
because like you gotta now worry about
that friend
yeah yeah and because i just think
different because i get like
like again it's the same reason i
rejected the guy that was too good
looking
yeah because it's just i get i get
nervous like i'd rather just
i don't want a guy that nobody else i
don't know i guess i can't win
i don't i don't know